[Music]
good morning the uk is ramping up its
diplomatic efforts over ukraine this
morning as russia continues to mass its
troops on its neighbor's border it's
also putting a thousand british troops
on standby in case of a humanitarian
crisis in eastern europe should the
russian military build up escalate boris
johnson is in brussels this morning to
meet the nato secretary general before
heading to poland later on he's issued a
warning to russia that nato member
states will draw lines in the snow over
the ukraine crisis
meanwhile the foreign secretary liz
truss is due to meet the russian foreign
minister sergey lavrov in moscow today
she's expected to urge the kremlin to
cease its aggression over ukraine in
what is the first visit to moscow by a
uk foreign secretary in more than four
years in a moment we'll get the latest
from moscow with diana magnay but first
let's take you to brussels ali standing
by for us this morning hi ali talk us
through what's planned today
morning k yeah that's right the prime
minister boris johnson will effectively
be reiterating his support for nato
saying that britain won't flinch we'll
be meeting the secretary general jens
stoltenberg here in the next couple of
hours worth saying too that kierstama
the labour leader will also be here
trying to show that labour too can be
tough on security and defense but boris
johnson will be in brussels and then he
will also be going to poland today to
meet the polish president britain of
course have sent 350 extra troops to
poland over the last couple of days and
the prime minister today announcing two
that a thousand more british troops are
going to be made available to nato in
the event of a humanitarian crisis if
russia does decide to invade ukraine of
course russia say that is not their
intention they say that they are
protecting their own security both sides
say they want diplomacy to work as you
say okay we've seen a significant
stepping up in the diplomatic efforts
the last few days you've seen president
macron in moscow we've seen the german
chancellor olaf schultz in the u.s today
liz truss is in moscow meeting her
russian counterpart and tomorrow the
british defense secretary's going to be
in moscow so a significant stepping up
in the diplomacy but troops are moving
and on that fundamental point of tension
around the expansion of nato it's hard
to see the gap where there can be an
agreement both sides are standing firm
in a real sense that the next couple of
days could really be decisive okay
meantime diana what's the mood in bosco
well i think these are going to be very
hard talks um
liz trust will lay down the law she's
already made clear that she will call on
russia to stop its aggression against
ukraine to de-escalate um the question
is what happens then because if you
encourage and order russia to stay on
the diplomatic path there has to be some
reason for russia to decide to stay on
it um it knows that russia that the uk
has a large sanctions package ready to
go bear in mind that uk russian
relations are in a very dire state boris
johnson came here as foreign secretary
four years ago then the salisbury
poisonings happened
so relations have only deteriorated and
now we have the possibility of war on uh
europe's on europe once again so it will
be a tricky conversation it's a
relatively short conversation but i
think what boris johnson said today is
really the nub of it he said there has
to be real diplomacy not coercive
diplomacy now russia seems to be using
coercive diplomacy to try on the on the
face of it to secure legally binding
security guarantees and it will need a
creative solution if the west and russia
are to try and broach this impasse
and we'll see whether in the next few
days the uk manages to make any headway
at all on that
okay ladies finale thanks so much indeed
of course we'll cover that throughout
the course of the day here on sky news
for you let's look ahead now in a bit
more detail to the prime minister's
meeting with that nato secretary general
jens stoltenberg fabrice pothier is a
former head of policy planning at nato
and is joining us now hello to you thank
you for joining us on the program how do
these um sort of talks go what happens
well i can't really i was not in the
room but what i can tell you is that
it's pretty obvious the uk is playing a
front role in this crisis and and i
think
johnson has managed to score some
significant points in showing that the
united kingdom remains europe in power
not only because of this meeting with
the nato secretary general but because
of the the fairly close relationship
with leaders in poland but also
the uk's commitment to ukraine however
the real question mark is whether
johnson and the uk can be part of the
solution and this is more more
complicated because as your
correspondent said
the uk and russia have a pretty bad
relationship and it's very uh
unlikely that johnson will be sitting on
the other side of a long table
with president putin on the other side
the ukrainian ambassador to the uk was
here on the program yesterday morning in
fact and he was saying that he feels
that the
likelihood of war has diminished what's
your take
i i think it's very psychological uh
depending on who you talk to uh that
likelihood is is different uh what is
clear is that president putin is
maintaining the pressure uh there has
not been uh with a substantial
withdrawal of the forces that have been
uh masked across the russian ukrainian
border the exercise in belarus is going
ahead so so far i think you don't see
sign of de-escalation from the russian
side but rather of maintaining the
pressure and that pressure even when the
exercise in belarus will be over i think
putin has all the reasons to keep the
pressure because he's getting uh face
time and he's getting uh in a way
concessions from the west and nato so
why should it stop
okay and as far as president putin is
concerned though i mean he does have to
worry doesn't he about the threat of
sanctions which
will harm the russian people
yes but the fundamental weakness in our
sanctions kind of signaling is that we
have signal sanctions only if and when
uh putin will go on a significant
aggression against uh ukraine while
actually the ukrainian leaders
were arguing for sanctions before for
kind of preemptive sanctions
already now uh to signal that there is
already a cost in doing this kind of
escalation so yes i think the sanctions
are uh compelling but uh putin as long
as he stays uh on the other side of that
line in the snow
will not face any cost
ukraine wants to join nato good idea
i think ukraine is entitled to want to
join an alliance it's a sovereign nation
it's a democratic one uh there are there
i think this is uh totally in their
right but obviously this is a decision
that has to be made between
ukraine and the 30 nato members and and
in a politically realistic way it's
highly unlikely given uh the conflict
between ukraine and russia and this is
what putin has achieved he has basically
de facto uh built for himself a veto
card on ukraine's membership to nato the
same with georgia and this is very
painful to see because ukraine
is strategically uh very important and
is basically on the front line of our
kind of defense vis-a-vis you know
western europe or broader europe and
russia
um finally um i told you uh what we
heard from the ukrainian ambassador to
the uk yesterday what's your view do you
think we are a little bit further away
from um a potential invasion
we are probably further away from
immediate aggression but we are not
further away from uh we are not closer
sorry from a solution uh because what
putin wants is something we
as nato but also the ukrainians
cannot and will not give which is
basically he wants to have a
debilitating say on on ukraine he wants
to own what is part of ukraine and since
2014 the ukrainian people have said they
are not interested in that
okay it's good to talk to you thanks for
your perspective much appreciated thank
you
just a reminder nine o'clock speaking to
the education secretary nadeem zahawi
who will be answering your questions and
we've had so many of them really
interesting set of questions both in
vision from some of you and also via
twitter and instagram and email using
all sorts of social media that to come
from nine o'clock meantime a look at
this morning's front pages for you the
guardians headline covered rules to be
abolished in england in a fortnight the
mail says england is leading the world
in ending coronavirus restrictions the
sun focuses on west ham footballer kurt
zuma's cats being rescued by the rspca
after online footage
showed him mistreating them according to
the telegraph
at least 50 people are expected to
contact or to be contacted i should say
in the next few days by the metropolitan
police investigating parties in downing
street during lockdown times also leads
on the mets investigation
there you go
staying with that
um tamara has more for us so um 50
people going to be sent questionnaires
does that include the prime minister 50
people being questioned we assume it
does because they are people who
attended those parties and we know that
he attended several of those which are
under investigation this questioning
takes the form of a of a questionnaire
but it is a legally binding one and
after receiving it which will be some
point this week they will then have
seven days to return it so it looks like
this police investigation is progressing
and another development yesterday there
was a new picture in the daily mirror of
this zoom quiz that we knew about
from december we saw the prime minister
with um a couple of other staff members
one of them with tinsel around his neck
but we saw pictures we've seen this
before but it's not like the angle where
we've got the bot the the open drink
bottle and one additional person behind
the laptop who we didn't know about
before that's three people so there are
now calls for the police to look into
that and they say they're going to ask
some questions about it so boris johnson
on the world stage today
pledging troops to nato but of course he
knows that this is coming down the track
and if he ends up getting a fixed
penalty fine then he's going to have a
very difficult time with tori and peace
did i pay for that bottle of champagne
and those crisps
that is a question that the police may
establish the answer to okay is the
taxpayer's money or
i assume a lot of what is what is uh
brought into downing street is taxpayers
money uh but the um but yes this party
which was initially not being
investigated because the people doing
the quiz were in a different room so it
was considered what the prime minister
was doing wasn't a party in fact members
of the cabinet said oh it wasn't as if
they were drinking or anything this
picture seems to put a different spin on
it but dominic cummings who as we know
is now gunning for the prime minister
says that there are better pictures
around including of parties in the prime
minister's flat so we'll see if anything
comes with that well there we go thanks
very much thanks a lot
uh the news came just hours after a
fresh photo emoj there you go of that
christmas quiz in number 10 as scotland
yard revealing officers um who
are looking into what happened at number
10 they will be as tamara was saying
looking into that in more detail
meantime we're going to be speaking to a
pig farmer calling for more government
support as the industry crisis goes on
is it the end of the pandemic as we know
it at 7 45 i'll be talking through the
prime minister's plans to lift all
coverage restrictions in a fortnight
and as i said don't forget at nine
o'clock joined by the in the studio by
the education secretary nadim zahawi who
will be answering all of your questions
she's one of the biggest stars of the
winter olympics so far
15 year old russian figure skater camila
vallieva's performance on the ice in
beijing has been hailed as one of the
greatest ever but the ceremony to
present her and her teammates the gold
medal for the figure skating team event
has been delayed for unexplained legal
reasons
and there are unconfirmed reports in the
russian media that she has failed a test
for a banned substance let's bring in
our sports correspondent um tom who's
standing by for us she's a young girl so
i'm guessing they're treading carefully
they are this is a big deal for two main
reasons kay and that is that as you say
she is a teenage prodigy at these games
the first woman to pull off a quadruple
jump in olympic competition she's a
sensational skater
but as you say the first
sign that something was wrong was when
the medal ceremony for her and the
russian team was delayed for
unknown reasons they won the gold medal
in the team competition she's due to
compete in the individual competition
later and her age at 15 is one of the
reasons why i think all of the officials
are treading so carefully they're very
limited in what they can say about
what's going on this is what happened in
a news conference in beijing when
reporters tried to ask the olympic
organizers what was happening
it was the doping case involving camila
valleva what kind of information do you
have can you confirm to the reports you
can imagine i'm not going to comment on
all sorts of speculation that i have
also seen
overnight and that speculation will
continue as i said as you said i had a
we had a situation arrive yesterday at
short notice um has legal implications
and i'm not and i hope you would
appreciate i'm not from the podium of a
press conference going to comment on
a legal case because it wouldn't be
appropriate
now the second reason this is such a big
deal is because she of course competes
under the russian olympic committee flag
and that is of course you may remember
that back in 2014 in sochi in russia
there was a state-sponsored doping
program that was exposed to the uproar
of the international sporting community
and if and it is a big if at this stage
if it is found that that has happened
again to any degree within olympic
competition it will all kick off and
there will be major
arguments and recriminations but at this
stage nothing has been proven and the
kremlin spokesperson has said we simply
need to wait for clarity as to what is
going on and that seems a pretty
sensible position at this point okay
thanks tom thanks a lot
meantime the fallout from the pictures
of a premier league player kicking his
cat one of his two cats continues with
both the player and his club losing
sponsorship deals west ham defender kurt
zuma faced a storm of criticism over the
video that was posted i should say by
his brother at the weekend melania is at
west ham's training ground in east
london they did he was played actually
wasn't either day night before last and
we had the mayor in the studio he wasn't
happy about that at all what's happening
now elena good morning
good morning kay the man was not the
only one who was pretty much outraged by
the fact that kurt zuma took part in
that game on tuesday now the burning
question is whether the manager david
moyes will include zuma in his upcoming
game against leicester city on sunday
now there was a sense that even though
the club condemned his behavior via
statement so in words their actions by
including him in the game made people
question how seriously they really took
it since then they've of course signed
the player two weeks wages which is
about 250 000 pounds but nonetheless
this backlash has continued take a
listen to what uh sadiq khan the mayor
of london said yesterday about it
it's despicable i think a number of
things need to happen urgently i think
the rspca and the police need to work
together to prosecute this player i'm
disappointed in david moyes and west ham
actually
i know how important three points i
support a club as well but i think they
should have shown leadership
and dropped him uh last night and i
worry when young people see
premier league footballers getting away
with bad behavior or prime ministers or
anybody else that thinks it's okay and
you can be successful that's why it's
really important for leaders and role
models and whether you're a footballer
or the mayor or you know journalists
we're role models and we should lead by
example
and what we've really heard the club is
sponsors peeling away so vitality their
official wellness partner said they were
suspending their relationship adidas
also dropped kurzima from that athlete
roster and of course the rspca has taken
in his two pet cats for examination
essex police alongside the animal
welfare organization are conducting
inquiries and there's an online petition
calling for zuma to be prosecuted that
has reached more than 225 000 signatures
okay thanks very much melania thank you
yeah i know that you've got very strong
views on that so many of you messaged me
over the last 24 hours or so the cats
are now in a place of safety they are
being examined let's see what happens
next looking at today's other headlines
for you
and world tennis number one novak
djokovic has been included on the entry
list for next month's indian wells
tournament in california organizers say
valid proof of full vaccination will be
required for entry to the competition
venue the 20-time grand slam champion
was unable to play in last month's
australian open after being deported
over his covert vaccination status in
other words he's not vaccinated
a bipartisan group of u.s senators has
agreed a deal to renew the violence
against women act bolstering domestic
protections for women in abusive
relationships it followed an emotional
plea from the actor angelina jolie who
said that the neglection of domestic
violence legislation in washington made
victims feel worthless
most of all i want to acknowledge the
children
who are terrified
and suffering at this moment
and the many people
for whom this legislation comes too late
the women who have suffered
through this system with little or no
support who still carry the pain and
trauma of their abuse
the young adults who have survived abuse
and emerged stronger
nasa has raised concerns about elon
musk's plan to deploy 30 000 satellites
into space freeing they could crash into
other objects orbiting the earth the u.s
space agency has warned about the
possible impact on future space missions
the uk's first hundred mile an hour
hybrid train will start transporting
passengers today the hybrid flex was
developed by adding a powerful battery
to a diesel engine it could reduce its
carbon emissions by 25 percent the train
will initially run from london to
aylesbury in buckinghamshire
and if you scan the qr code on your
screen right now you can listen to
today's edition of the sky news daily
podcast
pig farmers will hold talks with the
government later over the continuing
crisis in the industry yep it's still
going on we spoke previously to vicky
scott she's a pig farmer
and she is joining us now hello to you
picky vicky thanks for uh joining us on
the program so what's going to happen
today
okay so um the mpa the national pig
association have arranged a round table
meeting with defra the processors and
the retailers that's happening uh this
afternoon
in london
okay
what is the situation at the moment
where do you find ourselves i remember
previously talking about pigs um having
to be cold because there weren't enough
butchers available
um yeah that's still happening um
probably were uh worse than ever to be
honest
there's an estimated uh
extra 200 000 pigs on farms right now at
least 35 000 have been killed for
absolutely no reason
we've lost 10 percent of our producers
they've gone out of business uh it's
desperate and the government really
really needs to step in now and and
address this problem and do something
about it
yeah that pig doesn't like the sound of
that does he
how is it affecting your farm and your
livelihood
um it's extremely stressful um we've got
pigs backed up we've got about two and a
half thousand extra pigs on farms it's
costing us an absolute fortune um
and it's it's just not a it's not a good
situation to be in you know it's not
good for anybody it's not good for the
pigs it's not good for the humans and
something has to change
yeah i mean pigs are intelligent animals
aren't they i'm guessing it causes them
unnecessary stress as well
well we're doing our very best to
minimize the stress for the pigs um i'll
try and turn my camera around in a
minute but we've got about 600 piglets
staying on my breeding unit at the
moment that should have gone on to
third-party yards and they're looking
fairly happy so we're doing the best we
can to minimize the stress for the pigs
but financially it's crippling for
farmers
and it's just not right that we're being
forced into a situation where we have to
kill healthy pigs on farms
how could this have been avoided
um that's a very uh interesting question
and hopefully one that we're going to
get an answer to and make sure it
doesn't happen again basically the whole
situation has arisen due to a lack of
butchers in the processing plants
and despite the fact that government um
relaxed the rules in october and and
said we we could bring in more butchers
into the processing plants and actually
opened up private storage nothing has
changed
so we're asking government today to
again relax the rules and allow
skilled butchers in more easily but we
need more transparency within the supply
chain at the moment the supply chain is
very uh one-sided towards the processors
and the retailers and the farmers are
taking the hit uh financially and
emotionally and the government really
need to step in and address this because
before long there will not be any
independent pig producers left and
that's not a situation that anyone in
the country wants to see
okay i wonder if we might be able to see
your piglets before we go yeah on a
minute
exciting you could if i could work my
camera
here
got it
look at them how old are they look they
don't look too stressed are they
they're having a great time very very
happy indeed thank you thanks a lot
no problem thank you okay good luck
today thank you four legs good
now a ford motors factory has been
forced to close after truckers
protesting against a vaccine mandate
blocked canada's busiest land crossing
with the united states pressure is
building on the canadian prime minister
over covet restrictions amid warnings
the demonstrations could have widespread
implications here's martha kellner
this road would usually be humming with
the engines of thousands of lorries now
only the screech of resistance
[Applause]
some here oppose vaccine mandates others
oppose masks some oppose their
government entirely together they've
brought this border crossing to a
complete standstill the busiest land
link between the usa and canada now a
hockey pitch
right now we're hitting the elites right
where it hurts and this will stop it you
think they're listening you think justin
trudeau is listening they have no choice
but to listen they're losing money and
that's what elites don't like is losing
money i have five children
and when they misbehave
i put them on time out
to
change things and i think this is time
out for the government do you feel sorry
for people who this is affected
yeah in a way i do but at the same time
i think
the time that we're spending out here is
very little compared to the time that
we've all been cooped up in our homes
this is an absolutely vital trade route
between the usa and canada and it's now
been shut for three days
fears growing understandably for the
supply chains of the businesses who rely
on this room people's jobs people's
livelihoods and businesses in peril this
area on both sides of the border relies
on just-in-time deliveries for car
factories if this bridge remains empty
much longer they may grind to a halt and
the authorities are at a loss for how to
deal with the demonstrators the problem
that you see is they're hardened in
their position
but many there have also expressed that
this is a cause that they're willing to
die for
and so that elevates the psyche on the
ground to a whole different level where
police need a different type of response
because we don't want anyone to get hurt
copycat blockades have sprung up at
other cities and border crossings the
economic impact is untold even if their
message is confused these protesters
know that this has made them impossible
to ignore martha kellner sky news
ontario canada
looks pretty chilly there doesn't it um
certainly as far as the weather is
concerned let's find out what it's doing
here
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
southern parts mostly fine today while
the windy north and west will see
further potentially wintry showers
prolonged over scotland
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now everybody knows that diamonds are
forever but take a look at this beauty
the enigma is the largest known cut
diamond
in the whole wide world how beautiful is
that it's a black diamond
obviously weighing a staggering 555
carats and it went under the hammer in
london not literally for
3.2
million pounds diamonds like this are
very rare they've only been found in two
places on earth and scientists believe
its origins
may be
from outer space
let's take a look at some of the best
pictures making the morning papers for
you as well the guardian has a photo of
a wallaby in scotland as part of a story
about a row over plans to chop down
trees at a private island which could
result in them being cold and he's not
very happy about that is he and feeling
bamboozled the express has this picture
of a giant panda struggling to keep its
eyes open in its snow-covered enclosure
in eastern china wadey chose that one
for us this morning and the telegraph
has this dramatic picture of taliban
police recruits showing off their
training during a graduation ceremony in
kandahar
what are you doing
what's going on there then
i don't know and the times has this
adorable photo of a newborn bonobo ape
the first of its kind born
since
2019. hello you
and it's a try cross zoo in
leicestershire
looks a bit like me in the morning
still to come on the programme for you
we have got all today's top stories of
course what on earth is happening in
ukraine our prime minister is heading to
brussels and at nine o'clock ask the
education secretary don't miss it
[Music]
good morning everybody you are very
welcome to join us wherever you're
watching us around the world this
morning our top stories police are set
to begin contacting more than 50 people
believed to have taken part in lockdown
breaking parties in downing street
a russian figure skater's gold medal
ceremony has been delayed following a
legal investigation unconfirmed reports
in russian media allege that she failed
a test for a banned substance
and our main story so far this morning
boris johnson is in brussels for nato
talks and the foreign secretary liz
tross is meeting her russian counterpart
in moscow amid continuing fears of a
russian invasion of ukraine
love that picture because they're all
women did you notice that joining us now
lord ricketts former uk permanent
representative to nato between 2003 and
2006. hello to you sir thank you for
joining us on the programme this morning
what do we expect from this meeting
today with the nato secretary general
and our prime minister what could we
expect
well good morning kay um i think boris
johnson has the easier day than liz
trust actually because britain is a firm
supporter of poland where the prime
minister will be going later and has
been one of the most active countries in
terms of providing additional troops
additional support to nato members near
the front line with russia so i think
there will be a strong community of you
there
i think britain has played a good role
in showing other nato member states that
you need not just words but willingness
to put your troops into the
areas closer to russia
and then poland i think poland and
britain will have very much
similar approach to the crisis we need
both diplomacy and deterrence
britain has been more prominent on the
deterrent side of the argument but it's
good that liz trust is going to be in
moscow talking to lavrov today as well
so good to see britain at the heart of a
diplomatic surge at the moment
yeah do you think that ukraine joining
nato could be
part of the discussion
well i think nato has to have the right
to join ukraine like any other sovereign
country um
i don't believe that the west could ever
accept the russians demand that they
have a veto on ukraine joining nato
in practice it's not something that's
going to happen
while
russian troops are in the east of
ukraine but i don't think nato could
ever bargain away their right to join
nato at some point
i was speaking to um
another interviewee about 20 minutes or
so ago and pointed out to him that the
ukrainian ambassador to the uk was on
the program actually yesterday here in
the studio and he was saying that he
felt they had edged further away from
war than where they were a couple of
weeks ago what do you think
i think i would say that the cost to
putin of going ahead with a
invasion of ukraine and all the dangers
that have gone up the west is now better
prepared
ukraine has got more modern weapons
there are sanctions packages ready to go
in a way if putin had moved in a
lightning strike six weeks ago
i think the west wouldn't have been so
well prepared now it is better prepared
and there is just the sketch of the
possibility of an opening um on a
diplomatic track uh which president
macron seems to have made possible with
his visit earlier in the week we'll see
whether there is anything in that but we
need both to be um arguing as strongly
as we can with putin to start
de-escalation and remember there are big
exercises starting today between russia
and belarus which is not at all far from
the ukrainian capital
not just to de-escalate but also that
there is something in it for him in
terms of
a negotiation he's got our attention now
the west is fully um on this issue and
putin needs to decide i think is he
going to use that opportunity to try to
develop some sort of long-term dialogue
with uh western countries about how we
can all live peacefully together on this
continent of ours or is he going to
throw that away with a reckless
invasion of ukraine you mentioned
belarus there i wonder if there's any
significance in that given that uh
belarus um along with ukraine uh decided
to leave the soviet union some 20 years
ago is is there anything that we should
read into that
i think the whole putin's strategy here
is to surround russia with a buffer zone
of states which are pro-russian or under
russian influence because he has this
paranoid fear that nato is somehow
anti-russian and a threat to russia
which of course it isn't so in georgia
in belarus and in ukraine his aim i
think is
regimes which are
favorable towards russia at the moment
we have 30 000 russian troops in belarus
they're said to be holding exercises and
i think those exercises are now said to
last 10 days
if at the end of those 10 days putin
pulls back those troops and their
equipment from belarus that would be a
first important sign of de-escalation in
this crisis
and very welcome
if on the other hand they stay there
and they they offer a permanent threat
to ukraine's capital then i think the
risk is growing that the putin wants to
lock in the sort of deployments he's
made now and and produce some sort of
frozen crisis around ukraine which still
constrains
ukraine's ability to make sovereign
decisions
and that's really something we'll need
to avoid
good to talk to you thank you so much
for taking the time to join us my lord
thank you thank you thank you
child cruelty offences rose by more than
a fifth last year over 28 000 abuse and
neglect crimes were recorded by police
in england and wales joined now by vicky
nevin senior policy officer at the child
protection charity the nspcc hi thanks
for joining us on the programme was this
because of lockdown
good morning kate
yes well lockdown has put really
increased stress and pressure on
families and for children who are living
in violent homes they were perhaps
locked in that home with their abuser
we've seen some really
you know tragic child death six-year-old
arthur labino hughes 16 month old star
hobson um
eight week old i'm nfa johnson and we
know that in 2020 to 21
500 children died or were seriously
harmed due to abuse and neglect and the
nspcc helped blind knows that the
youngest children were most vulnerable
to abuse and neglect
we contacted agencies about the youngest
children on average 25 times a day and
that was about children aged five and
under to investigate physical abuse and
neglect
so what do we need to do as neighbors
obviously previously it would have been
teachers for kids the school age that
they would pick up on whether they were
quieter or whether they were suffering
bruising or whatever and and alert the
authorities that didn't happen during
lockdown a lot of kids as you say were
locked up with their abusers but going
forward what do we need to do as
next-door neighbours to keep an eye on
kids
yeah well it's really important that
everyone plays their role in keeping
children safe and if you're worried
about a child you can contact the nspcc
helpline we can give you free advice
and help to pass on that concern
as needed
because you know it's important that
there are um eyes and ears in the
community for children and you know
keeping them safe helping to share
information if there are worries
what are we looking out for
um so
signs of physical abuse might be
unusual
injuries um
signs of neglect a child
you know could not may not be
appropriately dressed uh they you know
may
be looking undernourished
uh these kind of signs uh and obviously
you can also perhaps tell from a child's
body language they might disclose
and something to you and it's really
important that that is taken seriously
and that that information is passed on
to the nspcc or the relevant authorities
so we can keep those young children safe
okay it's um it's good to talk to you um
this morning it's just so tragic though
i can't i can't even begin to comprehend
how somebody would want to hurt or abuse
a child you get a lot of calls to your
helpline
yes we do and
um you know there has been this increase
and that's why we are calling on the
government to take urgent action because
there is a health and care bill
that's currently before parliament and
this is the first opportunity since
those tragic deaths for the government
to prove that it's serious about child
protection and so there's a restructure
of local health systems and health
professionals play such an important
role in spotting signs of abuse and
neglect particularly for children who
are not yet at nursery or school and
might not be seen by other people and
professionals so we need to make sure
that the health profession is in a
really strong position to work together
with the police and local authorities
and we want to see that made clear in
the health and care bill
yeah we do we do thank you for
highlighting that for us thanks a lot
thank you thank you the number uh for
the rs uh the
um
nspcc helpline is 0808
five thousand oh eight oh eight eight
hundred five thousands bit of a clue
there as to what we are going to be
doing next the covid restrictions but
let me just give you that number
0808 800
thousand
still to come the government says it's
time to learn to live with covid but is
it right to remove all remaining
coronavirus restrictions in england
latest on that
[Music]
hello again everybody welcome back to
the breakfast show just have a quick
look at these pictures uh just reached
us actually all the way from moscow
where the foreign secretary liz truss is
laying a wreath at the tomb of the
unknown soldier
she's there to take part in talks with
her counterparts about the continuing
situation in ukraine as far as our prime
minister is concerned he has gone to
speak to the nato secretary general in
brussels today moving on to
poland
after that
other news for you now
and boris johnson made an unexpected
announcement during pmqs yesterday that
he hopes to lift all remaining curved
restrictions as soon as a fortnight's
time a month earlier than previously
planned but was it a welcome surprise
for everybody
let's speak to devi schroeder who is a
professor of global public health at
edinburgh university medical school hi
thanks for joining us on the program
this morning it was certainly a surprise
is it a welcome surprise
um i don't think it'll be a welcome
surprise to most people i think we have
lifted most restrictions we're getting
out of lockdown we're getting normal
life back vaccines and therapeutics and
testing have enabled that but to release
isolation i mean isolation is about
stopping someone who's infectious
passing that on to someone else it's i
think too early right now we have great
lateral flow tests they identify if
someone has a high viral and if they're
infectious we have a system where if you
test negative on that after day five day
six you can get out of isolation i don't
know why you changed that right now when
we still have over 200 deaths a day to
covet okay
i i read an interesting article um that
you were involved with in the guardian
where you said humans are social we need
to hug dance sing and recognize each
other's faces and smiles
um just looking at that i mean
so you do think that we need to get back
to normal as quickly as possible but
what you're suggesting is that it's just
too soon
it is and i think if you look at the
timing i mean it's really clearly to
create headlines today and distract from
the problems that the prime minister is
facing which is that he seems to have
broken lockdown rules which many people
other people had to face accountability
for and actually had consequences for
thinking of the chief medical officer in
scotland who had to resign there are
many people who broke what rules and had
to face the consequences and we're now
having a shifting of the dialogue
towards discussing the end of the
pandemic because there's a need to
create a diversion instead of looking at
that issue and saying the scientific
evidence isn't there right now to
completely release isolation for someone
who's actively infectious
so you think he's just doing it to take
away from what's been happening with the
lockdown parties at downing street and
the police investigation
yeah sadly i think that's the case right
now and the good news is we are heading
towards a time where we probably will
not have to isolate hopefully in a
couple months when we head into summer
when we understand more about waning
immunity the boosters how long they last
for those who are vulnerable and elderly
we know that the system we have now with
vaccines and boosters lateral flow
testing and therapeutics antivirals and
hospitals are making this a manageable
disease we have largely defanged it
taken the poison out of the bite of
covid19 but it still can bite and even
getting omicron after three vaccines can
knock people out for a week two weeks
this idea that oh we just have to
pretend it's gone because we say it is
is a bit foolish we should instead be
saying it's a serious disease still
killing over 200 people a day we've
accepted that death toll as a society
right now um what do we do to manage it
better going into the future while
trying to create opportunities for young
people address the cost of living
address heating issues and get back to
being a functioning healthy society
the covered 19 bereave families for
justice association uh are furious by
the announcement they're suggesting that
well over 1500 people a week are still
dying as a result of covid if all the
restrictions are lifted within the next
two weeks what's your advice to the
public
well i think the first thing is to do
the right thing so if you do test
positive and you're unwell stay off
until your lateral flow is negative just
to make sure you don't infect others i
don't think anyone wants that kind of
responsibility for what might be a mild
illness for you being a serious illness
for someone else continue wearing your
masks and public spaces think of crowded
spaces when you're in shops and public
transport you don't know who the person
next to you is and what they might be
facing in their lives or in their
families and um yeah just to continue to
look out for each other and recognize
yes we want to get back to all the
things we wanted to do before but to use
your testing use your vaccines get
boosted and let's get back to a healthy
society using those tools not pretending
cobit is just gone
okay good to talk to you thanks for
taking the time
thank you thank you thank you let's have
a quick look at some of these pictures
surgery uh we've already brought you
news about elon musk this morning um he
has a fortnight with nasa over plans to
launch thousands of satellites more bad
news for him it's uh given some
spectacular pictures for us take a look
these are the skies
there you go
above uh puerto rico and those are bits
of satellites that is spacex company
launched just last week burning up as
they fall back to earth they were hit by
a solar storm last friday which
effectively doomed the satellites and
have brought them back into the
atmosphere spacex has said the falling
satellites pose no danger to us back on
earth
and oh that's lovely actually i really
like that gorgeous and don't forget at
nine o'clock joined in the studio by the
education secretary nadim shalhawi that
is today at nine o'clock it should have
been as you know on monday of this week
but he was recovering from covid19 so
it'd be interesting to see what he
thinks about all of the restrictions uh
being lifted in two weeks time um just
he was i'm sure he used to be the
vaccines minister so i'm sure that he
was triple jabbed as well interesting to
hear his thoughts but we'll be talking
to him about education so many of you
literally thousands of you sending both
um tweets um whatsapps uh emails um
where else do instagrams um videos
everywhere so we've got we've tried to
hone them down as best we can the team
has certainly and we'll bring those to
you from nine o'clock coming up in the
next hour the prime minister heads to
brussels for nato meetings as a thousand
british troops so put on standby in case
of war in ukraine so the prime minister
heading to brussels he'll then be moving
on to poland meantime we've just seen
images of the foreign secretary
she is in moscow for talks with her
counterpart and she's been laying a
wreath at the tomb of the unknown
soldier today interesting to see who's
got the more difficult job at the moment
i'm guessing that the foreign secretary
will have some tough talking with her
counterpart in moscow prime minister
speaking to the secretary general of
nato as i said and then moving on to
poland after that and probably the
headline for us back at home is that
from two weeks time there will be no
more coveted restrictions in england
what does that mean to you and yours
talking about it with labour in just a
few moments do stay tuned
[Music]